bonjours welcome to play today my name
is Charlie and today three women is
gonna cook my favorite dish the beef
bourguignon
I'm Jean my name is Teresa AKA Freedom
my name is Samantha he looks familiar
guys you've been on a dating show before
yes I think it's F boy Iowa oh no this
is all scripted I know they kind of
ruined my images because they wanted me
to be one of the star of the show and I
didn't want it so it was it was kind of
a bad experience
oh poor baby because he seemed like a
nice guy
well I come from a really small town my
own time is anje I don't think you know
it it's like a postal code from the 17th
century I was no video Chef I was
Associated it's at the end when you have
all the plate a line on the table you
have to make them perfect seasoning the
sauce clean it up and send it to the
king I want a woman who makes me feel
comfortable to make me smile who's
simple who's gonna talk me about her
childhoods and not try to impress me for
what she have that's all I ask for I'm
from Northern Ontario Northern Ontario
Canada and my mom is from Trinidad so
I'm Caribbean and Canadian where I grew
up it was all French I went to French
school went to French high school every
restaurant had all French cooking secret
for working single mom crushed garlic
Frozen tastes the same in a man he
definitely has to make me laugh I'm
really ambitious I work really hard so
when I'm spending time with somebody
that I'm potentially dating I want to
feel that relaxation that ease I made a
Caribbean Buffalo I borrowed my
expertise from cooking curries and
paleau and then I added a touch of
Tamarind I think too often people follow
a recipe and they're not really paying
attention that happens in life you're
not really attentive and checking in
with yourself and you can be 10 years
and you're like oh what is this
relationship or what is this career and
yes I'm gonna be extra and say all of
that is in my dish
this is my Caribbean beef bolognao
smells really good oh okay I can smell
the onion in the mushroom as well but I
wonder what he smells like
the person who made that plate is really
meticulous because it's really well
organized the quantity as well is not
overflowing
looks like he likes it yeah
everything is well balanced the spices
the the one infusion is great the only
thing is the beef stew is a little dry I
would have prefer more tender well she
probably like active woman maybe in
charge of herself taking like running a
business he's smart you're doing it off
he's intuitive he looked fine I know
he's not gonna like my plate but I still
might text him
I mean now that I know that he cooks
does he have any children is he does he
have any student loan debt I'm from
Champaign Illinois my Heritage is
African-American and creole my granny
she always used to cook me Creole food
when I was a kid because she was just so
happy she's like I gotta let Korea all
day my Creole baby today I made oxtail
burgundy let this boil for a few minutes
before I add the instant mashed potatoes
don't tell nobody so oxtail is very
popular in the Caribbean in the South
African people from dysphoria that's one
of like it's like a soul food restaurant
so what I'm doing is basically combining
different cultures which I am French
cuisine Creole Cuisine and also a little
twist to California because I got that
Snoop Dogg wine for you put my heart by
Soul into this I should flip out dang
this really is instant I'm making a mess
I'm so sorry this is my oxtail burgundy
I think it looks delicious
he never had that before
well as I can see the plate is really
well served and generous there's a lot
of sauce I could hear him say sauce all
day long I swear I think that person is
really generous I am generous I am
he's gonna like it
see doggy don't
he's shaking his head well to be honest
there's not a lot of meat on that piece
it's really chewy and I would say the
meat is not cooked enough
uh it is this like a rubbing type of
like texture who is not really
comfortable on the mouth
and the seasoning is kind of off as well
I do like appreciate the attention to
bring something more cultural but it
doesn't click in all those memories that
I have about this French but it's new
memories y'all can make new memories
I'm originally from Ashland Virginia and
I was introduced to French cooking
through my grandma and my mom's side my
grandma grew up in Peru and she traveled
all throughout the world and that's
where she picked up her love of French
cooking I made it fresh beef bougain
Hill added lots of veggies I added a lot
of thyme too true to my character
beautiful culinary Picasso I'm looking
for something different in a man I'm
looking for someone cultured I think
that's what I've been missing is this
the first time I've attempted to cook my
grandma's dish on my own and I did it so
that's why I'm even more proud of myself
all right now that she's out we're gonna
garnish her this is my fresh take of
beef bourguignon oh your plant looks
nice oh my gosh
it's good it looks good as well there's
a lot of meats it's well structured
there's not too much of a portion no
mashed potatoes on that plate so it's
gonna be mainly The Birth boominium by
himself that's what I like as well it
means that the person goes to the
essential it's straightforwards they
don't play around don't try to make some
things what do you think about that I
agree straight to it I like it that
looks really good
oh wow yeah you can see he really likes
it well cooked well seasoned the meat is
really tender
it's a tasty meal is a tasty plate he
likes it well I think the person who
made the dish follow the rules follow
the recipes
maybe someone more perfectionist it
brings a lot of confidence to be able to
like just cook the principal dish
without bringing it inside I think point
with the confidence though I feel like
you really can't like you are very
direct I am I pride myself he's not what
I was expecting but I really do enjoy
that version okay well it is first of
all I want to really thank you for the
time you spend in the kitchen to cook
for me today I had a pleasure and I had
a blast trying all your dish but today
my favorite dish was yours oh my gosh
well I would like to take you on a day
to maybe one of my favorite restaurants
I love that it is
[Music]
thank you